did you ever have any moral qualms with
some of your missions that you got sent
on when you were
when you first got in there and you had
to get sent over i mean i don't know how
much of the work that
you were involved in was like part of
like regime changes or like greed on
parts of
yeah different things the us was doing
in other countries
so i worked um i worked covert influence
for a period and i loved it um
the covert influence yeah so there's
covert influence and there's covert
action
covert action um is like bay of pigs
right like they went in
and nobody was supposed to know that it
was america
um covert influence is much more subtle
it's
it's like um what russia does to us
basically um
you know changing hearts trying to
influence elections influencing hearts
and minds
um to get a certain result right okay
so you're really targeting people and i
have this social work background i
studied psychology for a bit in in
college
and i just thought it was so fascinating
like you think about your end goal like
where do you want people to get to like
what conclusion do you want people to
get to
and then how do you lead them there
verbally right through propaganda or
through newspaper articles or through
um you know just verbal
like ideas right like idea sharing
um you know dropping leaflets right like
it's just such a fascinating process to
me so
covert influence i would say was the
closest place where i
i thought i was luckily never put on
anything that i
felt was super dicey um there we
did i did learn that uh the government
there are rules so that was something
that was actually comforting because i'm
in this office
and um we were trying to plan something
and then the
lawyers are on all of our projects and
they're like
you cannot do this and we're like oh and
they're like you
cannot incite violence like you cannot
put anything out there that's going to
make people like if you think in any way
that it's going to make people
violent towards each other you are not
allowed to do that
and i was i felt it just made me feel
better i was like all right there's
rules here
like lawyers on my case like that's
great like
hooray you know let's do this you know
right black op
and you know with with some morals here
um but yeah there's definitely been
things done
in cia's past right that i wouldn't have
agreed with
i was lucky never to be in a situation
where i was
you know where i was not looking to
never be put in a position where
i had to decide whether i was going to
go along with something i was
not comfortable with or whether i was
going to have to leave
because that's always an option you know
and when i was interviewed that was one
of the questions they asked me
because i'm buddhist i was a social
worker and the
interviewer was like how do you
reconcile these things
about you with all the gray area the cia
is going to have and i was like you know
you just decide
on the spot like you have to decide case
by case there's no black and white
every situation is completely individual
so yeah i i really love
what uh how andrew described the
the difference between black and white
and good and bad like people's
people's moral judgments that they make
in the real world
by and large are good or bad
right or left and it's all funneled into
these
two binary categories and
it was super fascinating to me how the
cia
expanded that view and that way of
thinking the critical thinking
and the the cognitive uh what was the
word the cognitive
uh dissociation or something like that
yeah the basically
how the cia adapted a black and white
way of looking at the world
into a basically a color wheel of not
just gray areas but actually color
to where you have to analyze situations
depending on the different
elements and the different information
that you're getting from people whether
you completely disagree with this person
if this person is
the scum of the earth child murderer
whatever it could be
but you need to
be in this person's life and deal with
this person in order to get
valuable intelligence from them right
because that was super interesting
yeah and i i mean for me personally part
of that's like what's the greater good
here
right like maybe you're dealing with
this horrible person
but what are they giving you for the
greater good
i think on the other hand like most
people
so i worked with a lot of refugees and
there are
absolutely horrendous stories about what
happens
to people who become refugees before
they become refugees right so you read
all these horrendous stories of like
child soldiers and you know p like
neighbors turning on neighbors and rape
being used as a weapon of war
and like like there are so many
scenarios out there
that the average person who lives a
comfortable life
does not eat like cannot even comprehend
and when you're in a scenario
where essentially every decision
is would be considered a bad decision
where like
in your black and white it's all black
you still have to choose
and you have to be comfortable with
whatever that choice is like you can't
just stand there
you have to make a choice so you can't
put everything into a good and bad
bucket
there's a giant gray area of
um you know like if
if i have to choose between
between dealing with like some kind of
horrible
person who has ties to terrorism and i
know that they are going
to be able to give me information that
stops an attack that saves
50 lives like you're gonna give that
dude money
you're gonna take him out like you're
gonna be friends with him
because he has the ability to do good on
the other end whether he knows it or not
right like those are the real life
choices
that's what happens in real life i think
that when you are living
i mean and i i live a comfortable life i
just happen to have had the exposure
right i think when you're living a
comfortable life and you're not exposed
to the
like to the realities that are out there
it's easy to judge it's easy to judge
and be like oh
i wouldn't have done that i wouldn't
have done that okay well when you are in
these situations and you're standing
there and you have to make the decision
let's see what your decision actually is
right and you have to change
i think your idea like you have to shift
from
what's right and wrong to what is the
objective right especially when you're
doing stuff for the for the government
like military
cia um like what is the objective here
what is the mission here and how do you
accomplish that
it's not about what do i personally
think is right and wrong
how do you obtain your objective how do
you complete your mission
because that mission is serving all of
us right like whether we know it or not
there are missions happening right now
that maybe we would disagree with
but they're serving us they're
protecting us right
yeah i talked i had one guy on here who
was uh he was a
a drone pilot yeah for flying those
drones over yemen those killer drones
and he was like
he was recruited by i believe it was the
air force that was
that was heading that program but he was
said he was like
19 years old 18 years old and and they
were having him
pull the trigger on these drones that
were blowing up you know
people and him being 18 years old
watching people get
ex you know blown up in countries like
yemen or whatever and it scarred i mean
it really messed his head up
yeah having to make those decisions and
or whether he was making the decisions
or not he's probably following orders
like
pulling the trigger on those drones and
watching these people suffer like on the
king watching the infrared camera these
people like crawling and bleeding and
yep yeah that's gonna be terrifying to
you like
any human right and think about like
like all the people involved in that
decision right so he was pulling the
trigger so he probably felt
directly responsible but there's a chain
of command right there are other people
making that decision people who found
that location
to target like the guy in charge who
makes the decision to target it
who like people who know that that house
might have the guys kids in it do we
target or not
right like there are there
there are tons of people who are
involved in this decision
and it there are so many factors that
weigh in
right and i i don't it's
it's a sad reality right like i
i don't advocate collateral damage and
war
but it happens and it's a reality and
people have to make those decisions war
is not clean
it's just unfortunate and i um
when we were working uh we were working
the middle east and i was working with a
delta force guy and he was the nicest
guy ever like a family man he
um he had actually like his own
non-profit that like
helped women learn self-defense and just
the nicest guy
and he was teaching this triage class
and starts telling this story
about you know missions where he went in
like his missions were specifically to
go in and kill
people right like you and your
team are going to go into this place you
are going to kill the people there
like you know very close range shooting
or hand-to-hand combat like telling
stories about
team members that he lost on those
missions um
and so i asked i asked them i was like
what kind of psychological care do they
give you because there's no way
so for the cia they do a ton of
psychological testing
beforehand yes before they hire you so
i'm assuming that
part of all the special forces is also
tons of psychological testing
um you know what on paper and
you know through exercises to make sure
that you are not going to break
because not everybody has the mental
fortitude to do something like that
so he was saying that you know before
they go out on a mission
they go out and the team is together and
they go through exercises
every day to like be in the mindset to
be in practice and they have
psychologists on site
that they talk to and they like are you
know they are debriefed by and after the
mission they are also debriefed
um and that there's a ton of mental
work that goes into that type of work
because you have to like you can't
you know you watch you watch james bond
or ethan hawk or whatever and they have
like their issues but
they just kind of bury their emotions
like that's not
that's not real like these people go
home to families
you know like most of the soldiers out
there the intelligence officers they
have families back home like you have to
be able to reconcile it
somehow you have to find a way so at the
cia
we have actually in-house psychologists
and medical staff that you can talk to
if you need to
but you you know for the for the deltas
it was a part of
their mission for us like you have to
know to go talk to them
right like you have to be comfortable
being vulnerable in those areas because
if you are not comfortable
being vulnerable and taking care of that
yourself that actually becomes a
vulnerability for you and in the
intelligence industry
that's huge like you want to have no
vulnerabilities because that's what
outside intelligence forces
will target